all right guys so that was a little bit
more involved than I was hoping for
programmed it now we've got two
keys hey guys welcome back to the
channel hope you're having a fantastic
day in today's video we're back working
on some mods on my son's 2018 Ram
Tradesman if you've been following along
we've been doing quite a bit of stuff to
the truck I'll leave the links down
below to the playlist and everything if
you want to see where it started off
until where it is today uh but in
today's video
this truck when we purchased it only
came with one key and I absolutely hate
that when the dealers do that we got it
from a Ford dealership so of course
they're not going to go above and beyond
to worry about trying to get a second
key for it uh we had that happen with
another vehicle we purchased in the past
and it's always kind of a nightmare to
pay the expensive prices of the the
original OEM keys from Dodge or any
dealership and then the programming
costs that come along with it so uh if
you hadn't noticed by the thumbnail or
the title we're going to try to use use
some OBD2 connectors Bluetooth to a jcan
app on our iPad to see if we can't
program another key for this vehicle so
we've done some research we've got all
the parts I'll show you what we got on
the bench over here I'll leave all the
links to everything that we purchased
down below so if this goes well and you
want to do this yourself you'll have
links to to uh where we got it just
bought most of this stuff off of Amazon
we got the new key from keyless Joe keys
I think if you Google that again I'll
leave the link down below uh and
everything else everything was pretty
pretty cheap you can find these OEM
Dodge Keys online for like $90 plus uh
with keyless Joe I think I got it for 49
bucks so you can save a lot of money if
if this goes well of course and so uh to
to buy that and it it's exactly the same
again I'll show you here in just a
second but that's what we're got to do
today um in doing so though uh we did a
test run and I found out that you have
to uh for the software and the connector
and stuff if you want to change other
settings on the vehicle you can do so
but you have to have a security bypass
cable to do that I'll show you that more
in depth too but the main point of this
video is to try to get that um extra key
uh program so if we get into emergency
or the other one fails or we got a
problem we got a backup so that's what
we're going to do today if you want to
follow along please hit subscribe I'd
appreciate it hugely uh click like if
you found it helpful or informative and
and if you got any questions or comments
leave them down below I try to answer
everything for everybody but let's show
you what we got on the bench and what
we're going to do so here's what we've
got on the V bench uh we've got the
vgate iar pro Bluetooth adapter so it
plugs right into your OBD2 port
underneath the dash on most all vehicles
and you can check them out again that
link will be down in the description box
but we've we've already tested this out
they've got and it's it's working
flawlessly here's our Brand New Key
again exactly like like Factory it even
has the embossed Ram logo exactly like
Factory comes with a battery and
everything ready to go uh you can hear
it's not doing anything to the truck
it's not programmed so hopefully we'll
resolve that shortly uh with this it
comes with a with an appbook with all
kinds of software that you can use
there's number one is the
jcan that we're using on the iPad over
here uh but there's all kinds of stuff
in here there's uh Torque Pro and all
kinds of other Pro programs Alpha OBD is
another one I think a lot of people I
have researched and seen people like
that one a lot but we we went with the
jcan program and so once you have it
plugged in your car you can pick from
all kinds of different vehicles and of
course we're in the ram category and
then you've got all kinds of different
1500s 2500s year models and makes and
everything so this will work for quite a
few different vehicles and then while we
were playing around with the settings
for a a test run trial run we found out
if you want to change stuff like you
know uh door code not codes uh Chimes
and parking lights and daytime running
lights and tire sizes and all that you
can do that with this but you need what
is called a security bypass cable and so
this will allow you to plug that adapter
here into there and bypass your security
so not going to spend a lot of time on
that I'm going to make another video
about that if you want to check in in or
subscribe and we'll we'll pick up with
that in another video but we did get
that I'll go ahead and leave the link
but in this video we're just going to
worry about this key so let's get it all
in the truck and see what we got guys I
wanted to jump in really quick in the
video and tell you I would suggest
trying to program your key without that
security bypass cable from the start
your making model might be different
than ours and we were doing more stuff
in the video like I was saying
programming tire sizes daytime running
lights and other stuff so that's why
you'll see in the video we remove the
dash to get to the security box and use
the cable so we just did it all at one
time but you may be able to save even
more money not have to buy the cable and
I would definitely try that first before
you ripped everything apart if all
you're wanting to do is try to program a
new key but anyway let's jump back to it
here's a look at the app while we're in
it so you once you're connected to it
Bluetooth you've got your dash dashboard
modules and adaptation so under
adaptation if I can do all this and hold
it you can see so we're under the radio
uh Hub settings and then we've got to go
to ignition key if I get my stupid hand
out of the way ignition key programming
transponder programming mode beta so
it's still in a in progress but so we
need the transponder mode not the one
for push to start um pass keyless entry
and and starting uh not for this vehicle
anyway so here we are we're going to
click on that before we do that we've
got to get our pin
reading it says unknown all right guys
so that was a little bit more involved
than I was hoping for so we could not
seem to get the uh Alpha OBD app we
downloaded that and tried it we tried
the jcan app couldn't get that one to
read the pin number from the module
either jumped online to the ram Forum
real quick did some research found out
that people downloaded another app
called the Chrysler pin poer app and
I'll leave a link down to that below as
well um the app itself is free of course
to pull the pin from the module like we
needed it you have to buy credits or
tickets you get 15 free tickets and
there's a few things you can do for free
but of course we needed uh 50 tickets in
order to do it so it cost us $14.99 to
buy the tickets I was a little hesitant
but I said well short of taking it to
the dealership like most other people
did so some people had luck with that
did it for free some people uh got
charged for it downloaded it it only was
available for Android that I saw so I
did not see it for my iPad or uh Apple
PL uh Apple Store and so I was able to
download it on my phone which is why I
didn't video it and it pulled it
immediately got the PIN number so now
we're swapping back over to the iPad
going to punch it in see if we can
program this key finally all right so
now that we're back on the iPad uh we
we've got our pin number we're going to
try this again and see see how it goes
so we're back to ignition key
programming
transponder uh it says warning may be
unsupported that's okay no big deal
we're going to hit that we're going to
hit
go and it's going to say to program
additional key fobs we're going to say
go and ignition must be in the lock off
position while running this function so
we're good there we're going to hit go
please wait enter your vehicle PIN
number so this is where we read it out
from the other one it'll be unique for
everybody so we're going to tap in there
and we're going to hit
go
waiting please ensure unprogrammed I
didn't even read that wait two seconds
all right guys so that was just my fault
uh the the software was so fast I
thought it was going to prompt us to to
put the new key or the unprogrammed key
into the ignition but it assumes you
already have it in the ignition so
before you hit start uh it says to have
it in the off lock position go ahead and
put the new unprogrammed key in there
then hit go it reads it and it did it
almost instantly probably less than two
seconds and it said it was completed and
I said there was no way in the world it
did it that fast and we tested the
buttons and cranked the truck it worked
fine so little bit more more in- depth
than what we were hoping having to go
get the Chrysler pin puller app to get
the number off of it you may not run
into that trouble depending on your year
model make or whatnot but it wouldn't
pull it on ours for some reason on this
2018 so maybe it's just the way they've
upgraded them or changed something but
anyway uh pin puller app worked perfect
got it off of there plug the number in
hit the button programmed it now we've
got two keys it ask you if you want to
continue to program more keys you can if
you want to we only had the one extra
but now we have two so that was a
success we're good to go all right guys
another successful project completed few
extra steps than we originally thought
which that's the way every single
project ever goes around here but that's
that's just the norm but successful
that's the key word so we got in this
video it kind of maybe jumped around a
little bit because I was filming a
couple couple of different things in
here that we were trying to accomplish
the biggest thing the whole point of the
video was to program a spare key worked
flawlessly now we did have to get the
pin puller app I'll leave all the links
down below to all of this stuff that we
purchased off of Amazon um the key that
we purchased the bypass cable Bluetooth
connector and uh and the apps that we
had to use for this too so uh we did
have to pay for a license for the jcan
app so you can do a couple of free
things in there but to use some of the
more advanced features you do have to
purchase a license I think it was $20
for a license it's locked to the VIN
number of the vehicle so you can store
multiple licenses and your garage in the
app which is pretty cool uh but you do
have to do that to do some of the more
advanced features in programming on the
truck so not a big deal still turned out
cheaper than it would have to have to
buy a key from the dealership get them
to program it all that stuff so we're
still ahead in that regard and it's kind
of fun to just work on the truck and do
some more mods and and uh customizations
to it so all in all worked out great
hope you enjoyed the video I gave you
some tips and tricks or figured out
where this thing was or how to get
around some of the issues with it if you
wanted to reprogram a key or do some of
these changes if you found it
interesting or helpful give it a thumbs
up I'd appreciate it immensely consider
subscribing we're doing all kinds of
stuff to this truck my truck other stuff
on the channel vacation videos Hobbies
travel all kinds of stuff you might find
interesting we've got a boat restoration
series we're working on as well so I
appreciate if you stick it around stick
around uh if you got any com M leave
them down below I try to answer
everybody's comments and I appreciate
you being here and watching take care
and have a great one bye